don't bring anyone love into this I'll
take that I remember I live 43 year olds
and met bill I don't know if I mentioned
this on the last one but I met I met him
in person I'd seen him on Chappelle show
and you know yes and lay at the height
of like its popularity and then I was at
Melrose this is like I don't know what
it was it was the year that you moved
here and he's at the bar and I just
started talking to him and he was like
yeah you know I walked here and I go oh
from where he goes Silver Lake oh my god
walked here from Silver Lake
he was like yeah kind of far go yeah and
I still in a New York sort of see yeah
of course we bit which makes sense and
he goes you know plus I want to be able
to see a little bit of the city it's
just like so much of it it's just like
you know just go go go go go everybody
up your asses you're trying to drive or
something so and I gave him a ride back
to his house I was like this is way far
for a walk and then right before he got
out of the car he goes uh do you want to
see me come yeah all right and he you
know he just jerked off and then he got
out the car was just a meet two stories
like I was I was I wasn't affecting you
weren't it so yeah I'm saying that I was
like that's pretty cool man and he goes
that's the secret to be good yeah and
too many comics listen to me but that is
the secret for all you young open my car
out there gotta start doing it more we
discovered that there's the weirdest
story anybody's ever said oh it's the
serial killer like tonne of the history
is a complete lack of emotion thank you
this happen yes yeah you know and I know
being missing from our stories the sound
of somebody gagged screaming in the
other room right now I know that you
yeah and I know that you suspect that my
husband is a psycho I've heard I've
heard about yes yeah no I know
and I've actually yeah and I've been
trying to prove this on this show for
it's just like you know his like Bud in
this Bud Light there's like psycho and
psycho light like he just he's not the
the high-calorie one that can't get
married and have kids right yes but if
you if his thoughts were a movie yep
yeah definitely nc-17 yeah he's a
functioning psychopath yeah you know why
because when I started dating involved
this is a true story when I started
dating Tom Segura back in 205 there were
red flags little stuff like when we were
remembering dead animals behind you you
know in the beginning you're all
lovey-dovey and and he'd be like I like
you so much I like you so much I just
want to gouge your eyes out
I want to squish your face and kill you
and put a sledgehammer in your head like
that stuff Tom you're like I love you so
much I just want to smash your goddamn
head in I'm being serious I know there's
I somebody said that about my kid one
time oh my God look at those feet I just
want to cut them off and I was just like
[ __ ] lunatic
yeah right there you can't you can't be
with a person like that so we got a
guest room
well I'm two kids deep now I think I
used to say like I want to put your head
through that dress yes yeah yeah but I
was like as an expression of love right
and there were other things too like
because you don't like love and you hate
that it makes you feel weak or something
that you want to violently take it out
right yeah and you know it worked out it
did actually you frustrated that you
knew you had no control over the love
that you had for your wife so then then
you just use starting to feel trapped I
think it was more of like I didn't know
how to express how good I felt you know
so I thought why you try to play like
dim-witted they're calculated yeah
you're everything you need to be to make
in this business yeah you just can't be
creative and just be floating around
like oh that tickles my artistic fantasy
you have to have a plan but you got to
leave your friends and family behind
this is all these things when Oprah
talks about women yeah you're gonna do
this yet she leaves all that part out
yeah you're gonna miss your children
growing up right yeah get to the top of
the mountain and you're going to be
alone and have no real friends and
there's a reason I never had children as
Oprah because I don't give I don't have
time for that [ __ ]
I wanted to [ __ ] take over the world
when I swing in this circle with both
hands you can't you can't carry a kid no
no I agree yeah the other side of it of
course you talk about me is that there's
a lot of people writing in that bill is
you know much more profound psycho no
never
yes no I'll tell you seen it no no I I
wouldn't do that but I also hope that
like his feet fits the it's I get away
with it being a redhead so everybody
thinks Oh Opie Ron Howard they think
like Oh India the guy who doesn't get
the girl the the [ __ ] awkward that's
what they think him he looks like you
know every time there's a [ __ ] serial
killer yeah that is the exact hairline
yep when they lead them out that is he
is the exact [ __ ] hairline yeah well
and also sweet guy that's that's why
you're an extra psycho and Bill deals
with his anger on stage right you've got
act these parts of your act they're very
the punching of the muffins it's very
aggressive he deals with his anger
creatively you suppress you push down
you push down what you're doing is
you're you're looking at me on stage as
if that's who I am like you got to talk
to my wife my wife lives with me and I
yeah I'm a [ __ ] lunatic but you
express the rage it comes out creatively
at least as what it also it comes out in
his personal life or you do you are you
angry at home over the dumbest [ __ ] yeah
the stupidest what what got you last
time yeah what's the hate I don't know
it's blind reaiiy got see red so I don't
remember just don't [ __ ] some [ __ ] you
don't remember I got a garage and it's
locked and I don't have my keys yeah
I'll just scream of course yeah yeah and
what is rehouse is down they'll hear it
can you imagine by the way she has this
trait if you think I'm bad what how you
would be with mr. burr over here so if I
drop my phone oh god damn it
right like [ __ ] Hey
what happened drop my phone oh yeah
because I had so much anger in my house
growing up
everybody's [ __ ] yelling all the time
and I don't like it why did you pick
this lunatic because he doesn't rage he
suppresses it yeah and then he'll let it
out a one big spurt like I'll really
piss him off and then he'll let it let
me have it
what you have it it takes like a while
let's let you hold the dog you poke the
dog you poke the dog I don't bite really
though yeah I bite yeah like what I'm
sure I'm way worse than him I don't want
you guys bicker
now hold on bill when you say of course
goddammit right when you forget the keys
what's the of course
oh that is that easy that's the movie
trailer that's not the movie of me
getting angry I mean this it Tourette's
yeah you just arrest I have like a
string it's almost like Carlin's seven
dirty words like I can't do it unless
I'm mad yeah I know [ __ ] is in there
[ __ ] yeah what about dog [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I go I go
mother [ __ ] God yeah yeah god
[ __ ] damn it but there's
something about pronouncing the whole
world it takes the edge off mother
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] yeah it just
it takes it away you know it's it's good
for you right there's studies about
people who like done by angry scientists
I got a lot of work to do on myself I'm
turning 50 this year so I'm already on
the other side of it so maybe the last
three turning fifties maybe the last
three holes of golf course you ever seen
a shrink before therapy yeah I went to
therapy well you went but you stopped
going well after a while it's just like
well you know I've told all the bad
stories and I'm always gonna have
problems it's just becoming like this
you know life long car payment now do
you have to come over here be like well
this happened yeah my garage door was
looked and I just I just felt like a
[ __ ] after a while like when are you
gonna just you know get off this [ __ ]
couch here and go Livia life and stop
having to talk to this [ __ ] person
yeah you're full of anger because you
don't flog yourself for for being vows
would you stop it like you have some
sort of psychology degree ten years in
therapy it's a lot I watched a football
for 40 years I shouldn't be somebody's
coach yeah then you're gonna like
superimpose your [ __ ] issues or the
psychos in your life on to me it's like
[ __ ] alcoholics they think yeah
always like oh yeah you're reading hey
you drink you must be like me yeah the
whole world because their attics oh
they're so [ __ ] self-involved the
whole world has to be like them yes I
agree I'm so glad you understand in our
place I'm the worst the worst I know and
you you know think you're a [ __ ]
shrink right now I mean let the guy be
going I want to ask Bill something is
this funny to you no Jesus
so those guys yeah what's going on
well he's backing into a mechanic's
garage oh it's in another part of the
world so he's just kind of you know
taking his time kind of getting it
aligned
jesus [ __ ] it's funny cuz y'all
laughing dude somebody gotta teach that
person a little throttle control look at
life life is cheap in that shop huh that
guy took it like a champ though huh yeah
pretty much man now but funny I saw you
laughing it's funny cuz it shouldn't
happen it's unexpected you die
yeah you know and it's no dream too but
you think that that don't you think it
part of the I think the guy in the red
shirt would be a little more concerned
unless he was the guy driving yeah isn't
it a little funny extreme
[Music]